[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone is Charlie happy holidays we
have a bunch of brand-new Rick and Morty
season four promos that they just
dropped a bunch of Comic Con news and an
early release date for season four
episode one that's right you do have a
chance to see Rick and Morty season four
episode one before everyone else
probably a couple of different times
because there are a couple of different
things are gonna be screening later this
year of course I'll be doing Rick and
Morty Comic Con videos next week in
season four episodes when they drop
later this year so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything
I'll do a special Comic Con Rick and
Morty giveaway next week too but these
promos are basically just a fourth of
July promo because last week was a
holiday week in a bunch of Rick and
Morty fake video game promos that we all
wish were for real games Adult Swim
games does roll out a lot of new Rick
and Morty games every year because they
do make a lot of money on their
merchandise as opposed to traditional
advertising like regular TV shows do but
these are all hardcore a fake cop show
starring ghost in a jar and most of the
parasite characters from Total Recall in
season two sleepytime Gary and duck with
muscles then a cool video game version
of that psychedelic cosmic apotheosis
sequence from world leader Lee
conspiracy when they all went through
the wormhole Morty's mind blowers with
the truth tortoise and then Rick and
Morty versus a giant Megamind Morty
I think when it comes to a lot of the
mobile games that Adult Swim rolls out
it just goes based on interest so
everybody goes crazy about some of these
special promos that they make maybe
they'll actually turn them into actual
mobile games at some point but the big
news on the early release date for
season 4 episode 1 is that it's
confirmed now there are a couple of
rumors about what might be happening at
Comic Con but it's confirmed that
they're doing an early screening of
season 4 episode 1 at the Adult Swim
festival this fall just like they had
the Adult Swim festival last year except
last year they didn't show off any brand
new Rick and Morty this year the
festival is happening right before the
actual Rick and Morty season 4 premiere
so that's why they're able to air the
episode early if you go to that festival
it's not quite the April Fool's Day joke
season 3 episode 1 was but you still
have a really easy way to see the
episode before anybody else if you can
travel to Los Angeles for the festival
that weekend and I responded to him
going like what do you want me to do
wave a magic wand and just make the
premiere of Rick and Marty happen just
because you asked and knowing that he'd
go yeah
I do like all right you get this one
that's happening Friday November 15th
and Saturday November 16th the Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 1 screening will
probably happen on Saturday night though
but tickets to the festival are pretty
cheap so maybe you make it to that maybe
not if you can't make it don't freak out
because it's happening really close to
the actual season 4 premiere before they
started making all these announcements
my early guess was is they would try to
drop episode 1 before Black Friday
because they sell so much Rick and Morty
merchandise and that's such a big
holiday shopping weekend they want to
get new Rick and Morty out to freak
everybody out and remind them oh yeah I
need to buy some more merch come with me
and we also get to keep one and we can
play Nintendo games because of the extra
long break between seasons I'm also
expecting at least part of episode 1 to
be just like the opening from season 3
episode 1 where they open with a scene
joking or referencing how it's been a
long long time since we've had new Rick
and Morty anyway that's how I escaped
from space prison Oh scary place Wow
Rick that's one heck of a story I sure
do wish I could have been there to see
it happen at the beginning of last
season we were coming off that huge huge
break in a pretty big cliffhanger and
even though the episode completely
resolved that cliffhanger Rick escaping
from prison the first scene was a joke
about them just brushing past that like
a big middle finger like it's no big
deal we're not even gonna address it why
would you ever want to hear me talking
about a badass prison escape but then
they actually deliver on it and show you
the process of Rick escaping from prison
and defeating the Galactic government in
the Citadel of Rick's there are a few
season 3 storylines that ended in
cliffhangers like evil Morty The Citadel
of Rick's bethe not being totally sure
whether or not she's a clone but Rick's
ending with fly-fishing Rick the
president and then coming home all
pissed off isn't really a cliffhanger so
just expect a toned down version of the
writers making fun of themselves winking
at how it's taken 84 years to get to new
Rick and Morty and maybe a joke about
how they actually got renewed for 70
episodes before they actually get into
the plot of whatever season 4 episode 1
is gonna be Rick and Morty announced all
their big comic-con plans last week and
it sounds like they do plan on showing a
Rick and Morty season 4 animatic or a
teaser trailer at their official Comic
Con panel that's going to be next
Friday afternoon so of course I'll do a
trailer video for whatever kind of
footage they show off sometimes TV shows
will also surprise the audience by
screening part of an episode or an
entire episode without announcing it
ahead of time so if you're in the
audience at their comic-con panel odds
are pretty good you're gonna see a lot
of season four footage but their panel
is only gonna be about 45 minutes long
and because episodes are only a little
over 20 minutes long I don't think
they're gonna completely stealth screen
the entire first episode there there is
a special Rick and Morty screening
happening Saturday night at Comic Con
remember it's not this Saturday it's the
week after that they could also show
footage from season four episode one at
that or it could just be another episode
from season three they did the exact
same thing the last time they came to
Comic Con but remember because of the
break they skipped Comic Con last year
it's been that long some people forgot
that they completely skipped last year
2017 was the last time they came and
that was the week before season 3
premiered so because that was the year
they did the April Fool's Day season 3
episode 1 joke they just rescreened
season 3 episode 1 at Comic Con but
either way if you're a huge fan odds are
pretty good you will see some new Rick
and Morty footage at Comic Con some of
that might make it online so whatever
ends up happening I'll do a video for
that new stuff you guys have any clips
that you would like to show when they
come to Comic Con they usually bring new
footage of some kind either a completed
clip or an animatic teaser like when
they came during the break between
season 2 and season 3 even though they
weren't premiering the new season for
another year they still brought an
animatic teaser from that pickle Rick
episode that's how long ago that was
that's from 2016
[Applause]
Spencer Grammer the voice of summer
actually posted this picture from behind
the scenes she's recording dialogue for
the last couple of episodes there's a
lot of evidence pointing to there only
being ten episodes in Rick and Morty
season four there was a big question
about how many episodes because of the
70 episode renewal but a little while
ago Dan Harmon did a joke with a bunch
of post-it notes for Rick and Morty
season five ideas because they're
already breaking stories for Rick and
Morty season five justin roiland left a
comment talking about only 60 more
episodes and because he was talking
about season five that meant that they
would have done ten episodes for season
four so that's why everyone thinks that
there's only gonna be ten episodes per
season of Rick and Morty going forward
so tentatively that means seven more
years of ten episodes per season so by
the time they get through those 70
episodes you will be seven years older
some of you will probably have children
and be married while I was making this
video too they also just announced a
contest to be a new character during
Rick and Morty season four it's just a
charity contest like they did for season
3 they held a contest and then the
person that won got to do a voice for a
character this wound up being that
character during the Morty's mind
blowers episode who doubts his religion
after Morty's like I sure hope there's
an afterlife hope your religion is
correct and there's actually a hell that
you're going to go to then it totally
winds up being true
that was just a totally normal person
that won that contest he actually did a
pretty good job with his voiceover
dialogue so there's a chance that you
could actually do that during season
four but the contest doesn't say what
the character is going to be or which
episode is going to happen during so it
could wind up being interdimensional
cable you could be a contestant during
one of the TV shows during that because
they did say they were doing
interdimensional cable volume three
but everybody rejoiced there's so much
more Rick and Morty stuff that's going
to be coming between now and the end of
the year we don't have that much longer
before new episodes drop so if you have
any special requests for Rick and Morty
season for videos or Easter eggs or
anything like that just let me know in
the comments as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you'll see all
the Comic Con videos when I post them
next week but I will add a special
playlist at the top of my channel
homepage so it's easier for people to
find the Comic Con stuff while you wait
for everything click here to learn about
all those rick and morty season 5
episodes the Dan Harmon was teasing and
click here for all my other Rick and
Morty season 4 trailer videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]